[Music]
is it
Gareth Dave hi again hi neither one of
these I brought you here to show you a
really terrific cartoon from 1935 okay
it was created by
Iwerks Abbas do you know of I works as
literally what happens when someone
accidentally gets like a stick in the
eye
they just go up and then they look up
and they go I works I works that was
close
so herbs my dad's name oh this is weird
is it was it on purpose is that a name
that anyone intentionally gets yeah okay
just sounds it just sounds what
masculine yeah I was just gonna say it
just sounds like what a man would have
oh yeah let's just watch the this is
called balloon land hey man I'll let you
know when you say something I find weird
and so far nothing so let's watch herbs
balloon lands up Iwerks yep okay just
like it says commie color those Russkies
you're gonna learn so much about
balloons I doubt that right there oh I
did not know there was balloon as an
actual but when you let them go they go
up there yeah they float oh yeah they
are this is what they look like in the
wild some balloon cameos Laurel and
Hardy
try the Chaplin Hitler oh sorry Charlie
Chaplin back out weird so it's just
various balloon people okay uh-huh
so these are sexually active balloons
Shh don't shush me so this is the
number-one place then I take acid yeah
and then they have a come tree so oh no
and then I'm barren and then they have a
waffle makes balls sure for sure no that
works out and then they just put a bunch
of the tree come yep so this is how they
make balloon people here oh they
flattened them and then they inflate
them so this is some sort of hell you
know this is life this guy so he's
telling them don't put a pin in yet just
don't let a pin area everything else is
good pop you both
if you don't take care Oh such trash in
the flash I will settle his hash the
first part of the rhyme scheme was awful
he's a good nice pass sharing a bash and
I'll see you mister trash I have like 5
balloon rap albums do you far they from
up your father so they so they are brand
new balloon people and they just went
straight into a crazy for it yeah but he
seemed really cocky right like yeah
that's giving him much like don't let
pins hitch and he's like [ __ ] you old
man it's a haunted forest and there's
pins everywhere I see that's better now
it's gonna get weird
oh no the man with the pin cushion torso
and the huge boner nevermind but I mean
it's hard to not know he has a penis and
a know that he has the reach he does
have a penis come around for sure
he hates the believer he's uh yes and
now we have an enemy trying to pop the
balloons she doesn't seem hard you
didn't know what his motivation is you
just know that he likes to pop things
we've got to take the root of this war
where did the balloon then pin war start
I mean you know the balloons have been
invading ten countries for years I kind
of feel like it's just fun to pop
balloons I agree I agree that so he's
not good at popping balloons he misses
them a lot but he's really touching that
member of his sometimes isn't it he's
and now I'm out we're on the right guy
he's come on oh I mean it was a good
plan in the end I guess the story is
good right
no I the plot is great for sure and the
CGI is dynamic but here's the thing that
people don't know is back in the 30s
balloons were super racist probably the
only reason why they invented color for
cartoons was to display racism at this
time he's not very smart
obviously okay so so that's the end of
that guy
I'm glad we're over the most
uncomfortable balloon racism I've ever
encountered okay so this is a you sound
an alarm and balloon
what is Blumen oh okay but it works yeah
narrow and ours freaking out freaking
out now they know that pincushion man is
coming there too
well these two [ __ ] it what seriously
that's gonna work out
like that's not go well he delayed it
pretty well I mean this guy's clearly
just yeah oh right there sure would you
take care of the mess you created you
balloon people this is like a bad
strategy what is there a strategy well
the tree Oh No
has been coming for a long time oh no
he's not making white stuff anymore now
I'm gonna make a brown stuff I don't
want to talk about the hello it's coming
out of that tree anymore so they decided
to just go ahead and hit him and poo is
it yep
are you sure yeah that's how you take
down a pincushion guy are you sure yeah
my dad my dad it was a hunter okay so
the old poo and baseball trick that
doesn't make any sense well you don't
know what they're gonna do with it
yeah now they're firing its ass catapult
it is a scatter party has anyone talked
to him
no I find out what makes him tick why is
he like this clearly there's some issues
instead they're just gonna kick him off
the boat is a flat earthers flat
that's why I bet there's a bunch of
rounder throws up there I forgot to
mention that anyway it all worked out
except for all the people who died those
two are not my heroes
Finney so some people aren't good at
cartoons sometimes you have an idea you
should run it by other people but like
what was the idea the idea was just that
idea yeah I guess the idea was is there
any message a balloon and he was like
man what if this was a whole world right
okay right yeah and then went with that
and then but then if there's balloons
well there's got to be a there's got to
be a villain
so now you've naive now you understand
it no I don't understand it this was
disappointing ending it doesn't have to
be the ending I feel like it is just
because well now that we've talked about
how bad it went that is for sure the
ending
[Music]
you